for all the ups and downs i've had with
various star wars media products over
the past few decades
the formative space combat simulations
of x-wing and tie fighter and ms-dos
or at least my memory of them have
always been a fixed highlight
it's hard to go astray when you're
focused on the minutia of inherently
cool
sci-fi fantasy planes as opposed to
whatever's going on with jedi lineages
or space politics now
there have been a few arcade-style star
wars space combat games that filled the
20-year period since the last flight
simulator
and some of them were even good but star
wars squadrons is now making a welcome
return to some of the simulator
intricacies while still retaining a
large degree of the approachable
spectacle of the arcade-style flight
games
and based on the single-player story
campaign the balance squadrons has
settled on works very well
and creates an experience that makes you
feel as if you're really an active
participant in a star war
welcome to the nadiri dockyards i'd give
you a tour
but the empire knows we're up to
something now
they'll be looking for us which means
we have work to do
[Music]
the basic mechanics will be familiar if
you've ever played any kind of flight
game
you pitch a fighter up and down you bank
it left and right you fly forward
not backward and you can twirl until you
feel sick you maneuver your crosshairs
onto an enemy and you fire lasers or
missiles at them
you're locked to a first person cockpit
view of the action but all the
squadron's missions are in space
which means maintaining altitude isn't
something you have to worry about and
instead you get the wonderful freedom of
being able to fly along any axis
and rolling your ship and flying upside
down is a hoot it feels like you could
feasibly finish the squadrons campaign
relying mostly on those principles if
you wanted to
especially on lower difficulties and
that's great but squadrons digs a little
deeper with the ability to reroute power
on your ship
a system that brings a nice layer of
complexity in the advantages that it can
open up for you and the considerations
that come with that
each starfighter in squadrons has the
ability to rebalance their feet of power
to prioritize different ship components
the engines the laser weapons and on
certain ships the shield system
doing so gives you access to specific
benefits related to that system at the
cost of reducing the efficiency of the
others
diverting all the power to the engines
makes your ship more maneuverable gives
you a faster top speed and charges a
speed boost
prioritizing lasers will let you fire
them for longer and focusing on shields
will allow them to recharge faster
and even overcharge them to absorb more
damage than normal
furthermore ships with shields can also
choose whether to divert shield coverage
to the front of the ship
the back of the ship or balance them all
over it's not exactly on par with the
star wars simulators from the 90s the
power diversion isn't as granular and
you can't adjust your firing patterns or
anything like that but the notable
systems are there
and there's still plenty to think about
when you're in the thick of things
you can leave the systems equally
balanced and still be fine
but it's exciting to make these snap
decisions in the middle of a mission and
act more like the ace pilot you're
supposed to be
sure you could simply let your x-wing
cruise over the star destroyer and shoot
at its targeting module until your
lasers run out eating a bit of damage in
the process and then just
repeat it but you could definitely get
things done way more efficiently if you
shift power to your shields as you
approach in order to overcharge them
flip everything to your lasers as you
begin to fire to get a dozen more shots
in before you overheat
and then push everything to the engines
as you crank the throttle to get clear
quickly shifting all your shields to the
rear
to absorb all the turret fire coming
your way constantly having your mind
occupied with these mechanics on top of
your mission objectives can give even
the most straightforward sorties and
involved and exciting edge to them
especially knowing that you could be
putting yourself at greater risk if
you're in a bad configuration for the
situation
the commands are simple to execute then
mount to the d-pad on a controller by
default
though you can reconfigure all the
controls meaning the challenge comes
from internalizing the best options for
the situations you find yourself in
and remembering to change things up when
the time comes in the heat of the moment
of course the feedback you get in
playing with these systems does a lot to
make the experience really satisfying
and the tried and true star wars
production design is executed well
in squadrons the familiar sounds of
droids and proton torpedoes are weirdly
comforting
and hearing the crunch of titanium as
you fly past a tie you just obliterated
is very exciting
the unique cockpits of each ship have a
great look too with easy to read gauges
that don't betray the excellent retro
futuristic boxiness of the ships
themselves
i personally appreciated the extra touch
of 70's chic with some fantastic
hairstyles on some of the pilots
though a few of the cooler campaign
characters obviously didn't get the memo
across 14 missions lasting around 8
hours in total
the campaign of squadrons jumps back and
forth between the journeys of two pilots
each flying on one of the two sides of
the intergalactic war between the
freshly rebranded new republic and the
galactic empire
it all starts with a defection which
leads to a secret military project
and light musings on loyalty personal
morality and what constitutes a victory
while serving during wartime
it's a plot that succeeds in justifying
the escalation of exciting space combat
encounters if nothing else
the missions themselves are all
straightforward in nature all offering a
smattering of dogfighting as well as at
least one other objective such as taking
down a larger enemy ship
defending one of your own or hitting
stationary targets like reactor cores
and shield generators
there is some wiggle room for variants
and approaches or strategies but nothing
major
optional objectives crop up at times
that can serve as ways to make an
upcoming task easier if you're good
enough to complete them
later missions allow you to alter your
loadout and some even let you choose the
ship you take into battle
but for the most part a lot of these
variables are predetermined in such a
way that gives you ample opportunity to
get familiar with the game's meaningful
variety of vehicles and loadout options
what makes these missions special are
not the raw objectives though
it's the spectacle of some of the maps
they take place on squadrons takes you
to some exciting regions of the star
wars galaxy which are easy to appreciate
right away
colorful nebulas filled with lightning
storms star destroyer graveyards and the
shattered moon are just some of the
memorable stages for the campaigning
cannons
you don't need to be a star wars fan to
understand the game's events
there are a couple of brief but notable
cameos from the star wars canon
but more time is spent getting to know
the original characters the members of
vanguard and titan squadrons which are
the republican imperial teams
respectively
they fill their missions with practical
radio chatter but you get a better
opportunity to dive into their
characters
through optional conversations that you
can access before and after missions
vanguard squadron is made up of a ragtag
group of humans and humanoid aliens with
personalities as
varying as their colour palette the
confident one the timid one
the scoundrel titan squadron on the
other hand is an all-human squad
and while each character shares a hint
of backstory that explores how any sane
person in this universe could come to
join the fascist empire
all of that is betrayed by character
designs that strongly suggest that these
people are absolutely
definitely evil you've got menacing
scars elitist personalities an
ex-cop who loves delivering justice and
one guy who cannot take off his
terrifying
half-melted full face pilot helmet fine
get up fight again
for the empire needless to say despite
the welcome opportunities for character
interaction the limited amount of
face-to-face time you get to actually
spend with your squads means you're
looking to their lore and personalities
rarely goes
too deep and it's hard to form any real
connection with them
compounding this is the fact that your
two protagonists are both silent
despite character customization being
the first thing you're asked to do
part of which is choosing their voice
and personality your character is never
seen and really heard from during the
campaign
you can be an absolute hero who carries
the squad when you're in combat but when
you're simply hanging out in the
hangar you feel more like a fly on the
wall than a member of the squad which is
a bit awkward
conversations with your fellow squad
members are more like lengthy monologues
that you listen to politely
and toward the tail end of the campaign
you feel like a meaningless pawn being
pushed around to fight a few that you
have no feelings on
your character is unable to express even
a fraction of the hesitation or emotion
seen in the supporting cast
which undersells big story beats and
what little the game is trying to
accomplish in its thematic explorations
especially on the empire side but by and
large the majority of the campaign is
still filled with good scenarios that
push you to pilot your funky space
planes as best you can
of course the other major component if
not the main component of squadrons is
its 5v5 online multiplayer
there's a team deathmatch mode dubbed
dogfighting as well as the fleet battles
mode an objective-based tug-of-war
scenario between the two
main star wars factions in fleet battles
the republic and the imperial teams each
enter the battlefield with a battle
cruiser and two frigates with a goal to
push through the opposing team's
frigates
and eventually destroy their battle
cruiser you do this by building attack
momentum destroying both player german
and ai starfighters on the other side to
gain points which will then herald the
arrival of an ai driven corvette
that will automatically push into enemy
territory and help you attack the
capital ships head on
if you've ever played a moba or one of
the many multiplayer games that have
taken
inspiration from them then you'll have a
good grasp of the fleet battle dynamic
it rewards well-rounded team
compositions especially when each pilot
adheres to the strengths of their ships
whether it be fighter bomber interceptor
or support success typically comes from
coordinating with your team to attack
in tandem with your ai ships to make the
most out of each push
at its best these focused attacks on
giant flagships with a tightly knit
squadron of players capture the feeling
of star wars climactic starship battles
unfortunately like mobas your success in
and the overall pacing of fleet battles
can vary wildly
thanks to the whims of online
matchmaking unless you're in a party of
friends and have some kind of
coordination with them
fleet battles can be a slog in a party
of random players you'll often find
yourself in situations where no one on
the team is making enough of a concerted
effort to push when it's most opportune
to do so or defend when the dynamics of
a match shift against your squadron
at worst it can be a drag drawn out to
the maximum time limit of 30 minutes
where the natural ebb and flow of ai
ship spawns will bring the match so
exceedingly close that it might as well
be a coin toss to decide the winner
your efforts to rally your teammates by
pinging ships to attack or defend can so
often ring hollow
leaving you to make solo kamikaze runs
into capital ships in an effort to try
and nudge the needle in your favor just
a little bit
it can be frustrating and you think that
the general attitude among players would
be towards teamwork and playing two
objectives
especially given that fleet battles is
the game's only ranked multiplayer mode
but even in the most uncoordinated fleet
battles squadron still has the capacity
to create some excellent moments
like hiding your ship among some debris
amidst the chaos secretly bombarding a
capital ship at long range in your
y-wing and getting giddy at the idea
that the other team is going to catch
you out really soon
and then of course there are the
dogfights which are so easy to get
sidetracked by on account of the sheer
excitement of the chase
the flight options at your disposal as
well as loadout varieties offer many
ways to manipulate the jewel one way or
the other in the midst of the action
and the rush you get from close fights
can be incredible and that's not to
mention that the whole feat
is an audio visual extravaganza of
screaming engines shaky cockpits and
dizzying twists and turns
the thrills of those drills happen a lot
more in the dedicated team deathmatch
mode
naturally where the playfields are
smaller and there isn't any room for
confusion as to the objectives of the
match
but even though the mode is a team-based
one so many times i've hopped into
random matches and found myself
establishing a focused rivalry with just
one pilot on the other team
getting into exclusive cat and mouse
chasers throughout the duration of the
match
there's definitely a prevalent part of
the current multiplayer community who
love a tense dogfight
and have an interest in sizing up
against pilots at their skill level
rather than trouncing on a rookie and
when you find yourself in one of these
jewels
squadrons feels like the definitive
star-fighting experience
much like the campaign it's the maps
that play an integral part in
heightening these fights
though there are only six in total they
are all excellent playgrounds that make
starfighter chasers more exciting
with plenty of obstacles to zip through
and around at high speeds
i've had my most memorable jewels in the
dense asteroid field of gelatin
where you can throw all your power into
your engines weave back and forth
through a cluster of space rocks and
then suddenly loop the loop around
one and get right behind your pursuer
the same can be said of essels where you
can get rid of a tail by taking a risk
and flying down into the tight corridors
of the space station
keeping your enemy guessing as to which
hallway you'll go down next and maybe
dropping a seeker mine in a particularly
squeezy doorway as a surprise
the only real dud map in my eyes is
yavin which is purely empty space and
has no obstacles whatsoever
the avid matches in my experience are
always just bloodbaths of laser barrages
from all angles and at great distances
where your survival is entirely
dependent on praying that no one will
spot you as soon as you spawn next time
squadrons also features a progression
system that rewards two different
currencies to spend on unlocking
different ship components and cosmetic
items
and the game is notably free from
microtransactions simply leveling up
your profile will allow you to unlock a
variety of different loaded options for
either republic or imperial ships each
of which will give your ship a distinct
edge in one facet of its operation
at the cost of suffering in other areas
the currency for cosmetics is also
dulled out in daily challenges and it's
a slow drip feed
fortunately the quantity of truly
interesting cosmetic items is also quite
low
at least for my taste meaning the time i
needed to spend in order to afford the
things i wanted felt reasonable
the real reason that you're driven to
keep playing squadrons is for the pure
joy of dogfighting whether that be in
the game's team deathmatch mode
campaign set pieces or perhaps in vr on
ps4 and pc
with the sensory deprivation and head
tracking can give you an extra layer of
physical response to your flight
maneuvers
which can be exciting for as long as you
can stomach it the campaign's narrative
leaves you wanting and the flagship
fleet battles can be incredibly uneven
but the feeling of squadron's core
flight combat is gratifying enough to
sustain you through it all
the involved nature of juggling all the
tasks required to operate your cool
starfighter at peak efficiency
while soaking in the more mechanical
sights and sounds of star wars is a
stimulating experience that squadrons
just gets right
hey thanks
sir why not